hey everybody this is international
Master David puce for chess.com and this
is a lesson for beginners who want to
learn how to play The Glorious game of
chess today I'm going to teach you how
to move the king and uh rules associated
with him and how to use him in your
games so let us get started the king is
the most important piece in chess
because the object of the game the way
to win the game is to catch him and uh
the way you catch the king is you attack
him while attacking every single Square
he could possibly move to and no piece
of his can defend him can capture your
attackers nothing that is Checkmate okay
when he just can't get away and that's
how you win the game so you're going to
have to know how the king moves before
you can know whether or not you've
caught him so the king can move one step
in any direction that gives him eight
possible
moves which I'm now drawing here for you
making a little flower of legal
moves so those are the eight moves that
he's allowed to make but let's say he's
on the side of the board he may have
less moves than eight right how many
moves does this King have he has one two
three four five possible moves okay so
that's how the king moves if you wanted
to Checkmate him you would have to
attack him and each of those squares so
for example here's one of the most
famous possible
checkmates known as The Rook roller and
in this way white attacks these three
Escape squares with one rook and these
two Escape squares with the other Rook
plus the square the king is on and that
is a
Checkmate so the king is a slow mover
but also an agile mover right he doesn't
he doesn't trip ever he can sort of hit
all these squares around him and that
means that his fighting prowess is
actually pretty decent but let's now
talk about his fighting prowess with an
example so here is a
position
and in this case it's an end game and
you would want to bring out your king
and use him to fight even though if he
gets captured you lose the
game because at this point the amount of
pieces on the board are such that your
king is unlikely to get surrounded and
checkmated it's very hard for a single
Rook to Checkmate a king right there has
to be like no interference by the white
pieces and the white King has to walk to
the side of the board for The Rook Etc
it's really hard to to have that happen
and The Rook would need the help of his
own King and maybe his Pawns
so it's not likely to happen so white
would want to actually use their King
here but let's see I had the King on
this scare here to start but let's add
some other pieces to this
position so I'm giving each side an
extra
Rook Knight bishop and
queen okay so let's say you have this
position here now is the white king well
placed the answer immediately becomes no
when they are lots of pieces on the
board the only role for your king is to
hide that's all he's supposed to do okay
your king wants to be tucked
away and he wants to be in something
which is sometimes called a castle
basically the protection of some pawns
which are really cheap defensive units
that block lines along which someone
could attack your king so what would you
say of the placement of the black king
well the black king is placed a about as
well as possible because he's placed
where he has two pawns which block a
diagonal from which you could attack him
and a file okay where should the white
king ideally be placed in this position
here he should be in this corner here
right where he would be completely
surrounded by his own pieces and safe if
you have your kings out in the middle of
the
board you're going to find that he has
either checkmated or that tactics happen
on him even if your king were
I'm going to switch this around so that
he's partly tucked away even if your
king is partly tucked away any open line
to your king is a potential tactic
against you for example in this position
black could win the White Queen by
lining up a bishop with the queen and
king So any amount that your king is
exposed any open line to him is a
tactical asset for your opponent and a
tactical liability for yourself okay so
you really really want to be careful
about tucking your king
away in any position where your opponent
has significant pieces on the
board but the opposite is true once you
get to the end game now you want to use
him and now suddenly whose king would be
better placed whites or blacks well
whites because the time for tucking the
King has passed so this King over here
is not well placed what white can do
with the king is use to help promote his
Pawn this is a pass Pawn that can't be
blocked so the king is since he's a
short range piece and he's slow at
getting around it's very important to
place him exactly where the action is in
the end game and there are two tasks
that he's really good at one is eating
enemy pawns once he gets in among them
but the other and the one he's even the
best at is helping to promote his own
pawns so here you would move your king
towards this Square
here and I'm just going to show you that
your king is really good once he gets
there actually here let's do something
evil show you how to play against Kings
keep the black king from coming out now
that's mean right so black I'm going to
play some random move for him while I
continue to improve the white king and
you'll see that once the white king gets
here even The Rook can't fight against
him at all the king is really strong
here right so he'll just push that Rook
out of the
way and then he will move over here
and you see that this Square here he's
defending all squares of the pawn needs
to go through the queen so you can see
that if the black Rook goes behind
White's Pawn white can still just push
it and the Pawn's going all the way to
queening and Black's forced to sack The
Rook for the pawn because the white King
was there or what I could do is I could
put the black Rook here trying to
disrupt the white king and then then
white should probably defend his pawn
and
then sacrifice his rook in order to get
a new
Queen so there you see the power of the
king when it gets into good position
near its own past Pawn very very good at
helping it
promote so simple principles for using
your king in the opening and middle game
tuck and hide him in the end game bring
him out and use him get him close to the
action let me just show you one
important special move for the
king and that special move is called
castling and that is how you usually
tuck the king the rule is that if
there's no peace between your king and
one of the Rooks and you can do it to
either side if there's no space between
the
king and a rook you can move the King
two steps towards the rook and put the
Rook on the other side of your king this
is called
castling so you can play like this in
one move
right now with the white king castle
White prepares to fight in the center of
the board but black is going to hurry to
Castle his own King on the queen
side all right so see that again he
moves exactly two steps towards his rook
and then the Rook goes on the other side
of him so castling Queen side and King
side ends up looking a little bit
differently because one side of the
board has one more space on it okay so
quickly to know you cannot Castle to
escape from
check in other
words if I play this move for black and
white takes here with check black
wouldn't be allowed to Castle to get out
of check you would have to first capture
this piece and then you could Castle on
your next
move or you'd have to get out of check
somehow the other thing is if you move
your king you can no longer Castle you
can't bring him back
here and then try and castle it won't
let me because it's not allowed so if
your king hasn't moved your Rook hasn't
moved there's nothing in the way and
he's not in check you can
Castle again like this here castling and
that is how you get your king safely out
of the center of the board and prepare
for this kind of fighting here by
castling all right that's all you need
to know about the king so I hope you
enjoyed that and you can learn the other
pieces in other videos that we're doing
here
I hope you enjoyed this video and I'll
see you around on chess.com